♪ ♪
>> Laura: NOW BUILDING THE
WALL ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WASN’T JUST A SIGNATURE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PROMISE, IT WAS A
SIGNAL TO AMERICANS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY WHO SUFFERED THE ILL
EFFECTS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
BUT NOW THEY INCOMING BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS TELLING THE
SAME AMERICANS THEY WILL
BASICALLY BE ON THEIR OWN.
AND MY NEXT GUEST IS AN ANGEL
MOM WHO DOESN’T WANT TO SEE THE
WALL CANCELED.
JOINING ME NOW, MAURY MALONEY
AND HER SON WAS KILLED BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT TEN YEARS AGO,
MORE RAIN, INCOMING PRESIDENT
BIDEN ALSO WANTS TO GIVE
AMNESTY TO 11 MILLION ILLEGALS A
END DEPORTATION MY GUESS FOR
EVERYONE FOR 100 DAYS.
WHO CARES ABOUT COVID.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND TO
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS A SLAP IN THE
FACE AND WE ARE A COUNTRY OF
RULES AND LAWS AND LAWS HAVE TO
BE ABIDED BY.
SO AMNESTY TO ILLEGAL ALIENS,
WHICH COME UP WE REALLY DON’T
KNOW, 11 MILLION BUT CLOSE TO
20 MILLION HERE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND YOU ARE REWARDING THEM FOR
BREAKING THE LAW.
YOU ARE SENDING THE MESSAGE TO
OTHER FOREIGNERS OUR BORDERS ARE
OPEN.
IF YOU COME HERE WE WILL REWARD
YOU FOR BREAKING THE LAW.
>> Laura: NOW, IT IS REALLY
SHOCKING, IS IT NOT, MAUREEN,
YOU HAVE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF HONDURANS AND
OTHERS FROM CENTRAL AMERICA AND
ELSEWHERE WHO KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO GIVE THEM
ALL THESE BENEFITS AND CONGRESS
WILL PROBABLY GIVE THEM FREE
HEALTH CARE AND OBVIOUSLY, AN
EDUCATION AND SNACK BENEFITS AND
SO FORTH, BUT IT IS AMAZING HOW
WORD TRAVELS PRETTY FAST.
CARAVANS START AND THE POLICE
ARE OVERWHELMED.
YET WE HAVE THIS AMAZING
FORTIFICATION AROUND THE CAPITOL
BUILDING AND ALL OF WASHINGTON
IS LOCKED DOWN.
APPARENTLY, NO APPETITE TO
ACTUALLY PROTECT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> AND AFTER THE INAUGURATION,
THEY SHOULD TAKE ALL THOSE
NATIONAL GUARDS PUT THEM DOWN ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND PROTECT
AMERICANS.
WE WENT DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH
ON THAT.
HERE IS BIDEN DHS NOMINEE SAID
ABOUT THE MIGRANT CARAVAN AND
HEADING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> PEOPLE PRESENT THEMSELVES AT
THE BORDER, WE APPLY THE LAWS OF
THE NATION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THEY QUALIFY FOR RELIEF UNDER
OUR HUMANITARIAN LAWS OR WHETHER
THEY DON’T.
>> Laura: WELL, MAUREEN, WE
HAVE SEEN HOW THIS WORKS IN PAST
ADMINISTRATION AND EARLY IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY LET EVERYONE IN.
>> RIGHT, AND THEY GIVE THEM A
COUPLE OF YEARS DOWN THE ROAD TO
SHOW UP AND RELEASE THEM INTO
THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY NEVER SHOW UP FOR THEIR